痛いこんにちははじめ社長です皆さんは
身長というものを気にしたことがあります
でしょうかま私はじめ社長身長
186いやそのあの自慢したいわけじゃ
ないんですけども人間ってのはその身長と
か体重とか体の大きさとかっていうものが
あるんですけれども僕は本当ありがたい
ことに身長が186cmというあの比較的
大きい方の人間なんですよでなんかこれ
本当びっくりする話なんですけども動画外
で初めて会う人の80%ぐらいの人にえ
初見社長ってそんなにでかかったんだって
言われるんですよ本当に俺大きい風に見え
ますか皆さん実際やったらびっくりすると
思うんですけども結構でかいです本当に
本当びっくりするぐらい言われるのよでか
いって186cmなのであの覚えといて
くださいほら伝わらんかなかなか映像だと
伝わりにくいと思うんですけども結構
大きいんですよ実はただそんな僕も最近
悩みがありまして最近身長上がっ
たら縮んでたんですよ
1cm年だこれはもう年かもわからんなん
だろう年取ると身長縮むって聞くじゃない
ですかからちょっとなんかあれ俺身長この
まま縮んでくのかなと思ってちょっと心配
になったんですけれどもそんな中皆さん
身長を伸ばしたい時に飲む飲み物知って
ますかこちらセノビック皆さん知ってます
かセノビック成長期応援飲料セノビック
まあなんかこうカルシウムなのかな栄養
機能食品としてあるんですけどもこれねせ
伸びるんです
よ成長期は成長期だけなのかな成長期だけ
なのかなね本当に分かりませんがでも名前
がせ伸びそうじゃないですかセノビッグっ
てなので今回の企画はですね僕今日から
セノビック1ヶ月間飲み続けます毎日で
これでもうあの成長期も終わったこの
お兄さんがセノビックのって身長伸びたら
成長期でも成長期じゃなくても身長伸びる
ということがもう証明されるので僕がです
ね身長が欲しいというみんなの力になり
ますいやいやはめさん待ってください
あなたも身長高い86cmあるんだから
もういいじゃないですかて言うと思うじゃ
ないですか他人俺はねもっともっと身長
伸ばしたいと思ってる身長伸び切った
みたいなところがあるからここでこの身長
の186の男がさらに伸びたらもうマジで
効果あると思うので俺がこれで伸びたら
本当に皆さん背伸び飲んだ方がいいですよ
身長伸ばしたい人まそもそも身長っていう
のはねもちろんその家系とか血筋とかも
ありますよ遺伝とかでもねそれだけじゃ
ないと絶対思います食べ物とかカルシウム
の摂取とかたくさん寝たか寝てないかとか
悪いけどね本当に寝た方がいいよ科学的な
ことは分かんないけど絶対たくさん寝た方
が身長は伸びるから俺はめっちゃ寝てまし
たその中にこの骨を研究して生まれたセノ
ビッグこれ1ヶ月間このあのアサの男の子
男の子でもないアサのお兄さんが飲むと
身長どうなるのかちょっと1か月間
しっかり飲み続けて測ってみたいと思い
ますでは
行こうというわけでまずは身長測っていき
ます実際に僕の今の身長が何cmなのか
ちょっと測っていきましょう家に身長系
あるのちょっとおもろくないじゃ測ります
これはもうまず真剣なやつね行き
ますはいこれねこれねこれねはいこれが私
の身長
ですえっとえっとほら縮んでねやっぱり
180縮んでる
5.2とかじゃない
185.221.70.12つってやっぱ
年取ると縮むんですかねわかんないです
けどそんな成長期も終わったこの僕が今日
から毎日セノビックを飲んで身長がどう
なるのかちょっと皆さん楽しみにしてて
くださいマジで毎日飲み続けますはいと
いうわけで1日目です早速飲んでいき
ましょう俺ただセノビック飲んだことない
んだよなただなんか身長伸びるというのは
よく聞く話だし名前的にも絶対伸びるのよ
セノビックせ伸びるとビッグが多分かかっ
てんだろうねまさに身長伸ばす用の飲み物
です牛乳と一緒に飲むのが多分大事
でしょうねカルシウムしっかり取っていき
ましょうで飲み方がスプーン3倍分入れて
冷たい牛乳に溶かすだけでいいということ
ですええ1杯で1日分のカルシウムが
取れるんだねすごいな飲んでいき
ます牛乳牛乳牛乳牛乳
うわ粉コップ3杯分ってどんぐらいなん
だろなんバターナイフでいいかなこれこれ
で1杯分ぐらいかな1
杯うまそうでも2
杯3杯これを溶かして飲むだけってことね
美味しそうココア
[音楽]
みたい全然溶けねえまあまあいいでしょう
いいでしょうじゃ1日目セドビック
いただき
[音楽]
ます
ああ溶け切ってねなんかめっちゃダになっ
てますもうちょいちゃんと測って飲み
ましょうなあでも多い分にはいいでしょう
それだけ栄養が取れるってことですかえ
うまなんか甘くて美味しいミルクコカ飲ん
でる気分本当にこれ身長伸びんのマジで
美味しいだけなんだけどもうちょっとさ
その身長伸びるっていうかなんか味が独特
なのかと思ったら本当に美味しく飲み
やすい
ですあ案件じゃない
[音楽]
ですごちそうさでしたこれを1ヶ月続き
ます多分東京とかお仕事で行くことある
から一応どこ行ってもいいよに静岡用の
セノビックと東京用のセノビックと持運び
用のセノビックが準備したので今日からの
30日間はもうどこにいてもセノビック
飲めるようにしておきますいやもう187
とかになったらどうしよう普通に最高身長
超えちゃうんだけどマジでどうなるか
わかんない結果が楽しみです頑張り
ます2日目ですうん絶対ダになるんだけど
いただき
ます
[音楽]
飲み
やすどうも3日目です今日も作りましたダ
ですこれあったかい牛乳じゃないとダメな
のかなめっちゃダになるんだけどいただき
ます危な3日目もおいしい4日目です早く
飲まないと会議が始まっちゃうあうま
朝ご飯代わりになってるな今日も頑張り
ますどうも5日目です今日は東でちょっと
撮影してました東京にわざわざセノビック
持ってきたからねどこに行ってもちゃんと
飲みますよパボ危ねえ東京の家終わるかと
思ったこれも5日目だよなんか大体の目
分量で入れれるようになってきましたね
セノビック入れすぎたなもうセノビックの
申し事言っても過言ではないよしよしよし
よよよしでは乾杯いただき
ます
ちょっと薄いなもうちょっと入れても良い
のかもしれん
ねあ入れすぎたどうも6日目ですいただき
ます今日も東京でお仕事でし
[音楽]
たときてきたどうもなかですこれで1週間
セノビックを飲み続けてることになります
味は美味しいんですけどもやっぱ1週間
飲むとちょっと味に慣れてくるところが
ありますね今日もいただき
ますうままだ美味しく感じるもう東京3日
目ですね今日はこの後撮影で朝まで
ちょっと頑張るので撮影中に次は飲むこと
になるのかな今日も頑張りますどうも8日
目です今事故物件に来て撮影してるんです
けども事故物件でもしっかり
と飲んでいきたいと思います飲
て
汚ねえよ絶対シビック飲みたくないよ
こんな場所で衛星上やばい入れてき
ますごめんなさいね入って汚なく
て急にも入れていき
ます
私
いや絶対いつもより美味しくないせっかく
なので事件の現場があったとこに飲み
ましょうこぼした後みたいになってるけど
やいただきます
[音楽]
はい
ああここでもうまいどうも小目です今日も
飲んでいきましょうコップを透明なやつに
しようと思ったらなんか今日入れすぎまし
た大丈夫これチ料かいただき
ますうん絶対いりすぎてるけどしっかり
飲みたいと思いますでまた明日どうも10
日目です10日目にしてシェイカーを
使おうという作戦に出ますなんで初めから
気づかなかったんでしょうもう10日間も
飲んでんのかよく忘れずに飲んでるなって
いう感じではありますもう目安量でいい
です目安量で身長伸びろっていう思いの分
だけ入れればいいんですただ本当に混ざら
なくてなんかスプーンとかで混ぜてもダに
なるからこれシェイカーで飲むのが一番
いいのかなって思いましたプロテインと
一緒混ぜ
ますわめっちゃ混ざってる
うわあいただきます
うんうまい10日間のでも全然うまいです
はいというわけで10日間飲み続けてみ
ましたがちょっと身長上がってみましょう
かはってみますさあ10日間でどれぐらい
伸びてるのでしょうかお願いし
ますはいはいはいはい
はい
やばい11日目
ですいただき
[音楽]
ます12日目ですいただき
ますうめえ13日目
ですいただき
[音楽]
ます
セノビックのおかげかな筋肉ついた気がし
ます14日目です今日もしっかり
プロテイン違ったセノビック飲んでいき
ましょう今日で2週間ですねなんか筋肉
ついた気がするんだけどいただき
ます15日目です今日は東京ですいただき
[音楽]
ますああうめえどうでもいいですけど
髪の毛切って遊びましたどうも16日目
です今日も飲んでいきたいと思います
いただきます
美味しいのよ美味しいんですけどさすがに
なんか15日2週間ぐらいあたりから
ちょっとね飽きてきました美味しいんです
けど
うん17日目ですいただき
ます18日目
です19日
目マジで開けてきたなおい美味しいんです
よ美味しいのは分かるんですけどなんか
毎日日日として飲むのちょっとあきてき
まし
たごちれさでしたどうも20日目ですあと
10日間ですねもう袋がなくなりそうよく
20日間もやったな俺本当
になくなっちゃったまずであのセノビック
飲んでるだけなんですけど1つのことを
続けるのってね本当に大変なのよこんな
単純なことで
も飽きてきたもん20日目ですいただき
ます
20日目ということで途中経過で身長
測ろうと思ったんですけどもう楽しみに
取っときます20日目では測りません
ちょっとあと10日間続けてセノビック
飲んで最終日果たして俺の身長はどうなっ
てるのかお楽しみちなみに結構実感は
ある分かんないですけど頑張ります21日
目ですいただき
ます22日
[音楽]
目
23日目
[音楽]
ですおはようございます26日目ですあと
日入れすぎました結構きつい味に飽きてき
ました美味しいのは美味しいんですけど
あの同じ味を飲みすぎて飽きたって感じ
ですねあと4日頑張りたいと思います27
日目これを飲めばあと3
日
[音楽]
ああはい30日間経過しまし
た30日間セノビックを1日1杯飲み続け
ました非常に良かったですなんか
ルーティンとして生活の中の一部に
落とし込むことはできたんですけどあのね
美味しいのよめちゃくちゃ美味しいんです
けど味に開きましたねさすがにさすがに
毎日同じ味のやつをこの量を飲むってなる
と
結構飽きちゃってな1週間過ぎたぐらい
から割と普通の領域には入ってました
こぼれてね1ヶ月30日間飲み続けてこの
セノビックの袋が2袋半ぐらいなくなり
ましたね東京でも飲んでたんで東京にも
これあるですけど2袋と半分ぐらい消費し
た気がします1杯で1日分のカルシウムま
不足しがちですよ成長期じゃないこの成人
の俺とかもカルシウムはあって困ること
ないですから骨歯の形成30日間欠かさ
やりましたラスト1ぱいいただき
[音楽]
ますは開け
た30日間達成しまし
[音楽]
たこのわともついに今日でお別れかやや
寂しいのさあ30日間背のび飲み続けまし
た30日前の俺の身長って何センチだっけ
確かセノビック飲む前の身長が185
5.2cmだった気がします果たして名前
の通り背が伸びる飲み物セノビック30
日間成長期でもない初め長が飲んだら身長
が伸びるのか伸びないのか見てみたいと
思いますもう1発で決めますからね
いきなり
じゃあ失礼し
ます行き
ますはいはい
はいはいこれこれねこれねもこ今のです
からねこれでもずるしてない
からさ身長伸びてるのか伸びてないのか
[音楽]
点0.5mm伸び
た
[音楽]
お願いし
ますはいはいはいはい
[音楽]
はい
やばい10日目の結果え
185ぴったりぐらいじゃないかなこれ
ぴったりぐらいな気がするな180えなん
なら縮んでね185ないんじゃないか縮
とりけ